[Musica]
quando immagino il futuro io immagino
movimento incontri trasformazione e nel
movimento inteso come viaggio
nell'incontro e nella trasformazione che
ne è la conseguenza c'è un po il filo
rosso che unisce le mie esperienze
professionali di archeologa ma anche di
insegnante insegnando italiano agli
stranieri il viaggio è quello degli
studenti che arrivano portando con sé il
loro bagaglio di esperienze e l'incontro
quello sorprendente con il mondo
all'interno di una classe come
archeologa il viaggio è duplice
nello spazio e nel tempo ed è
altrettanto ricco di incontri e di
scoperte
il mio viaggio di archeologa e iniziato
nel 2002 a se nel cell tigri una delle
grandi metropoli del mondo antico una
metropoli multiculturale fondata nel
cuore della mesopotamia da un greco il
generale macedone seleuco primo l'erede
dei domini asiatici di alessandro magno
il mio compito a seleucia era quello di
schedare le oltre 8.000 figurine in
terracotta rinvenute durante gli scavi
della missione archeologica italiana
un numero impressionante di oggetti
proprio perché si trattava di oggetti
comuni di oggetti prodotti in serie e
diffusi praticamente in ogni casa
oggetti che potevano avere funzioni
molto diverse tra loro potevano servire
come giocattoli come oggetti di culto
domestico come offerte funerarie offerte
templari e proprio per questo sono una
fonte molto preziosa di informazioni sul
sentire sulla vita sulle abitudini dei
loro antichi proprietari un materiale
straordinario dunque frutto
dell'incontro tra la cultura greca e la
cultura mesopotamica il cui studio mi
avrebbe
pagata per i 10 anni a venire seleucia
abbiamo detto si trova in mesopotamia e
dunque si trova nell'attuale iraq un
paese in cui negli ultimi decenni
passato e presente sono entrati in una
rotta di collisione drammatica l'autunno
del 2002 il momento della mia prima
visita era il periodo dell'ultimatum a
saddam hussein
il periodo delle indagini degli
ispettori dell'onu per verificare la
presenza delle armi di distruzione di
massa in quei giorni mentre ios che davo
le terrecotte il personale dell'iraq
museum di baghdad
stava lavorando per mettere in sicurezza
i reperti più preziosi del museo nel
timore poi rivelatosi fondato di una
guerra imminente e di lì a pochi mesi
nell'aprile del 2003 sarebbero
rimbalzate sui media di tutto il mondo
le immagini drammatiche del saccheggio
del museo di baghdad e dunque archivi
sconvolti vetrine in frantumi oggetti
deliberatamente danneggiati o trafugati
si trattava della punta dell'iceberg in
realtà di un attacco al patrimonio
iracheno che era già iniziato
era iniziato negli anni difficili
dell'embargo e che sarebbe poi
proseguito in un crescendo di
devastazione di spettacolarizzazione
negli anni a venire
abbiamo ancora tutti negli occhi credo
la violenza delle distruzioni ad opera
dei miliziani dell'isis meglio dei
materiali delle statue del museo di
mossul e di siti fondamentali per la
storia della mesopotamia come nimrud
ninive ea tra meno pubblicizzati ma
altrettanto devastanti sono stati gli
effetti degli scavi clandestini
un fenomeno che ha conosciuto un
intensificarsi esponenziale proprio nel
periodo immediatamente successivo alla
seconda guerra del golfo con gli effetti
che potete vedere in questa diapositiva
interi siti completamente crivellati di
buche che alterarono per sempre la loro
fisionomia compromettendo il modo
irreparabile il loro potenziale
informativo
ecco è in questo contesto quindi un
contesto di crisi un contesto difficile
che ha operato negli ultimi 5 a 15 anni
il centro di ricerca con cui ho la
fortuna di collaborare da tempo un
piccolo centro con un nome lunghissimo
centro ricerche archeologiche e scavi di
torino per il medio oriente l'asia
dal 2003 a oggi le azioni in iraq del
centro che prima erano orientate
prevalentemente alla ricerca scientifica
si sono concentrate sulla salvaguardia
del patrimonio e sulla formazione del
personale addetto ai beni culturali
le azioni che come centro scavi abbiamo
messo in campo sono state molteplici
dalla realizzazione appunto di corsi di
formazione per restauratori conservatori
archeologi alla schedatura di materiali
trafugati che poi erano stati recuperati
dall autorità di polizia allo scavo in
zone danneggiate dagli scavi clandestini
ma probabilmente il contributo più
significativo dato dal centro è stato il
riallestimento di tre delle principali
sale dell'iraq museum di baghdad l'iraq
museum di baghdad che prima avete visto
non al suo meglio purtroppo in un
momento di grande crisi è in realtà un
luogo unico un luogo che custodisce le
straordinarie testimonianze di una
storia plurimillenaria una storia che va
dall epoca preistorica fino all'età
islamica passando attraverso le grandi
civiltà dei sumeri assiri e babilonesi
grazie al contributo del centro sono
state riallestite
alleria islamica la grande galleria
assira che conserva alcune delle
sculture delle lastre a rilievo che
decoravano il palazzo del re assiro
sargon secondo di corsa bug e la seconda
galleria assira che contiene reperti
provenienti da un'altra capital assira
che edin brut insieme ai lavori
strutturali alla realizzazione di nuove
vetrine di supporti espositivi più
adeguati abbiamo ricercato di curare
anche la parte comunicativa di appunto
quella di maggior interesse per il
pubblico con ap la stesura di pannelli
bilingui in inglese e in arabo e di
schede di approfondimento sulla storia
della mesopotamia dal 2003 dalla guerra
il museo di baghdad era rimasto chiuso
era rimasto chiuso perché le condizioni
del paese non ne garantivano la
riapertura
il museo ha riaperto ufficialmente è
stabilmente le sue porte nel 2015
proprio nel momento in cui i siti del
nord del paese subivano l'attacco da
parte dei miliziani dell'isis è stata
una riapertura fortemente voluta dall
autorità irachene e una riapertura con
una forte valenza simbolica che ha
proprio il sapore della restituzione al
popolo iracheno di un patrimonio che
essi universale ma che è anche e prima
di tutto locale dall'epoca dal momento
della sua riapertura sono tornata al
museo di baghdad due volte e devo dire
che mi ha molto emozionata vedere
esposti oggetti che avevo studiato per
anni oggetti che erano stati trafugati e
che sono rientrati a far parte delle
collezioni del museo ma soprattutto mi
ha emozionata vedere il museo pieno di
vita e di visitatori e quindi studiosi
anziani giovani coppie e soprattutto
tanti bambini
un giorno stavo studiando alcuni pezzi
in un angolo di una grande sala
semivuota
e sono stata circondata da un'intera
scolaresca da un gruppo di bambini molto
incuriositi dal mio lavoro e soprattutto
incuriositi all'idea di poter vedere
così da vicino senza neanche il filtro
di una vetrina degli oggetti tanto
antichi anche a loro penso quando
immagino il futuro e per arrivare al
presente oggi a baghdad e in iraq
l'attività del centro continuano
continuano gli scavi continuano le
attività di studio di ricerca continua
la formazione anche grazie alla
riapertura nel cuore del bar di baghdad
proprio a due passi dal su che dalle
tigri dal fiume del centro dell'istituto
italy rock iracheno di scienze
archeologiche un luogo fisico di
incontro e di scambio tra studiosi
italiani e iracheni
un luogo che come il museo di baghdad
era stato chiuso era stato saccheggiato
del 2003 e poi era stato chiuso per
lunghi anni l'esperienza irachena ci ha
insegnato molto
ci ha insegnato soprattutto che lavorare
con la comunità per la comunità ci piace
almeno quanto la ricerca scientifica ed
è per questo che abbiamo accettato con
entusiasmo un invito che arrivato da
molto lontano dalla città di car corinne
in mongolia car corinne sorge sul sito
dell'antica karakorum un'altra grande
capitale multiculturale del mondo antico
la capitale dell'impero di gengis khan
in cui convivevano buddisti musulmani e
cristiani a car corinne insieme alle
autorità locali e con l'aiuto il
sostegno di altre istituzioni italiane
stiamo lavorando a un progetto per
avvicinare i bambini al patrimonio
storico archeologico della loro regione
attraverso la realizzazione di
laboratori didattici e la formazione di
insegnanti
e operatori museali il nostro obiettivo
è quello di creare un ponte tra passato
presente e futuro per continuare a
cercare al di là delle differenze quello
che ci rende simili
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]